one of the basic but false expectations
people have in democracies is that they
get to vote on the things that could
change their lives forever nothing
happens we think that reorders the lives
of millions of people all at once
without some sort of a referendum or an
election or whatever now things have
never really worked that way of course
and for a few Generations now since the
Advent of modern technology that has
become more and more evident what
happens in practice is that some new
technology arrives and Life Changes
forever all at once for countless people
in one generation watching a movie meant
driving down to the theater buying a
ticket in person meant uh you know doing
things like putting on clothes and
interacting with other human beings no
alternative was imaginable but then just
a few years later watching a movie is as
simple as sitting inside your house
pressing a few buttons on a remote or
yelling commands at your remote like
some sort of schizophrenic it becomes
archaic to think of anything else so
we're all used to this kind of Rapid
social change at this point these
massive ships shifts happen before
anyone studies the facts that these new
technologies might have on our brains or
our interpersonal relationships the
changes just happen very quickly we all
take them for granted and that's all
very familiar
what's not familiar what most people are
not used to is what happens when there
is a roll back on all of this what
happens when a modern convenience for
one reason or another suddenly just
stops
well as of this week that's no longer a
hypothetical question after
screenwriters in Hollywood went on
strike a few months ago last Friday the
Screen Actors Guild joined them on the
picket line and the combined strike
means that for all intents and purposes
the entertainment industry in the United
States has been shut down doesn't exist
right now strike effects movies
television shows video games and more
it's the first time that this kind of
strike has happened in more than like
six decades I think in our always online
world of Netflix and Hulu and HBO Max
and Xbox Live Xbox Live this is
unprecedented and for some people it's
quite terrifying
for journalists and corporate media who
spend more time glued to screens than
anyone on the planet what we're seeing
is something of an extinction level
event this is a catastrophe
approximately on the scale of like a
texas-sized asteroid hitting the Earth
now these journalists didn't care much
about the explosion of that Russian gas
pipeline even though that might have
caused the world war they didn't care
about the strange disappearance of the
911 call from Jeffrey Epstein's jail the
night that he died even though that
raised a lot of questions shall we say
about corruption at the highest levels
of the federal government journalists
didn't bother to panic over any of that
but a strike in Hollywood
well they're all over that story
the Associated Press for example just
published this dire headline quote
Hollywood plunges into all-out war on
the heels of the pandemic and a
streaming Revolution
well that sounds pretty serious and
according to the allegedly venerable
Sunday show faced the nation on CBS it
is quite serious Face the Nation just
invited the former CEO of Paramount
Barry Diller on the show to explain the
Fallout of the ongoing strike in
Hollywood and here's what the Hollywood
shutdown means for you
and it's it has has really serious
implications okay this is what it means
for you according to Barry Diller listen
at this moment This Kind of Perfect
Storm it's okay if it gets settled in
the next month
but I'll posit what happens if it
doesn't
and there doesn't seem to be enough
trust and energy
to get it settled soon
what will happen is if in fact it
doesn't get settled until Christmas or
so then next year there's not going to
be many programs for anybody to watch so
you're going to see subscriptions
get pulled which is going to reduce the
revenue of all these movie companies
television companies the result of which
is that there will be no programs and at
just the time
strike is settled that you want to gear
back up there won't be enough money
terrifying stuff so the former Paramount
CEO wants you to know that quote what
will happen is in fact if it doesn't get
settled until Christmas or so the next
year there's not going to be many
programs for anybody to watch do you
hear that are you trembling in fear yet
there might not be any programs for you
to watch next year the programs are
going away think of the programs what
will you do without the programs
now it's kind of funny when you think
about it the implication conveyed with
total sincerity is that it would be
somehow a bad thing if people stop
staring at screens for 10 hours a day
actually went outside and got some
exercise and maybe developed real human
interests and personalities
Barry Diller is assuming that you'll
agree with him on that point that that's
all a bad thing as if it's a given
if people went outdoors and got some sun
berry Diller fears then one thing might
lead to the next and after a while there
might be you know
um thinking actual thoughts in their
brains
and interacting with each other
people's testosterone levels might even
go up
we simply can't have that profiling
surveillance and data harvesting are a
few things not to like about tech Giants
but what can you actually do about it
when you rely on so many of their
products well the good news is it
doesn't take much for you to take a
stand for less than seven dollars per
month you can join me and fight back
against big Tech by using expressvpn big
tech companies make their money by
tracking your searches video history and
everything you click on and then selling
your personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that's why I use expressvpn
on all of my devices to make it much
more difficult for them to exploit my
data for their own profits best part is
how easy it is to use the expressvpn app
I just tap one button on my phone or my
computer I turn it on it's as simple as
that look your data is your business you
can visit expressvpn.com Walsh right now
to get three extra months free that's
expressvpn.com Walsh to get to get
protected right now expressvpn.com Welsh
as many of you know I wasn't super
thrilled with my family got a dog but
they are obsessed with it which is why
despite my own distaste for The Mangy
Beast I love making my family happy and
part of doing that is keeping this
freeloader as healthy as possible which
is why I give my dog rough greens Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough grains dog food is
dead food everybody knows that nutrition
isn't Brown it's green but let rough
greens boost your dog's food back to
life rough greens is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins and
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
grains it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too Dr Dennis black
is so confident rough grains will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jumpstart
trial bag can be found and at your door
in just a few business days if you go to
freeruffgreens.com Walsh or call 844
rough 700 that's free Ruff greens.com
Walsh we're call 844 rough 700 today
what Diller said is interesting not
because he's worth listening to but
because his desperation is obvious
Diller and the rest of Hollywood want to
make sure that you're always consuming
content on one subscription service or
another
these people never pause to consider
whether the content they're forcing down
your gullet is good or worthwhile
whether it helps you to be a smarter
better more interesting person
whether it makes your life better
like these are actually things you
should consider before consuming any
content I know it's sort of unimaginable
that you would take these into
consideration at all
they never ask themselves if people
actually want to watch and listen to the
slop they're putting on these streaming
services and in movie theaters they just
expect that you'll be horrified of the
prospect that all this stuff is no
longer available that the morphine drip
of content has been shut down
unfortunately for these Executives in
recent months there have been a lot of
data points that contradict
their Theory here I mean look at the
pathetic box office returns of the new
Flash movie or the mission impossible
sequel that just came out uh performing
in a pretty mediocre way at least when
measured against expectations or the
Indiana Jones a Little Mermaid
catastrophes all of these failures
reveal that people are growing weary of
what Hollywood is producing they're
exhausted by it bored of it and the
numbers make that clear
for example The Flash had a budget of
roughly 220 million dollars and as of
the latest estimates it's barely broken
even
the latest Indiana Jones film cost
around 300 million dollars made about as
much in the global box office so that's
a wash
the latest Mission Impossible movie
meanwhile had a budget of around 300
million dollars as well as of today it's
only made less than 250 million dollars
now it's only been out for a week or two
but again well below expectations
these kinds of shortfalls happening so
consistently for big budget films are
unheard of in Hollywood I mean it's bomb
after bomb after bomb so what's going on
here
what could possibly explain these
numbers
rather than confront that question
honestly corporate media is rushing to
blame can you guess covet according to
uh the AP quote disaster loomed in
Hollywood when kova 19 and March 2020
shuttered movie theaters empty TV
studios and shut down all production the
recovery is still ongoing box office
remains about 20 to 25 percent off the
pre-pandemic pace
now in other words by the media is
telling the problem isn't the content of
these Hollywood movies it's not that
people are tired of woke propaganda or
derivative storylines or franchises that
tell one story repeating itself Ad
nauseam never coming to a conclusion
that's not the problem the problem is
that more than three years ago covet
happened and that's what explains all
this so it's like the same excuse that
the government used to fundamentally
change the election system in this
country is also the same excuse that
explains why no one is watching
Hollywood movies anymore that's that's
what explains everything whatever the
corporate media needs it to explain
something they can always pull out covet
and say well that explains it
and it's always covered by the way that
they blame not the shutdowns it's not
the rest it's not the government's
response to kova but covet itself
it's all a pretty Pat pretty neat
explanation but is it true well let's
see
because if that explanation made any
sense whatsoever you expect that every
movie regardless of genre would be
having similar problems do you expect
that viewers would be tuning out across
the board that's not what's happening
not even close the film sound of Freedom
which tells a true story about a hero
who rescued sex trafficked Children is
currently pushing a hundred million
dollars of the box office
word of mouth is especially strong the
film's audience in its second week in
theaters grew by nearly 40 percent
and now you might say well it's 100
million dollars it's less than uh 200 or
300 million that's say Indiana Jones
made you said that was a failure
but the difference is that sound of
Freedom manage to make all that money
and build all that buzz on a shoestring
budget of less than 15 million dollars
that's one five
somehow the pandemic from three years
ago didn't cut into their revenues how's
that possible
when all said and done sound of Freedom
will likely earn something like 10 times
its production budget and put that into
perspective for Indiana Jones 5 to earn
10 times its production budget it would
need to make
three billion dollars at the box office
and to put it simply that ain't
happening
as it happens it's not just sound of
Freedom that's reaching a large audience
on a small uh budget the Christian
horror film nefarious managed to make it
into the box office top 10 despite
basically no marketing no budget no
stars
nefarious came out at the same time as
the Super Mario movie and still managed
to beat expectations and there are many
more examples of this also this year of
course my own documentary what is a
woman became arguably the most viewed
documentary of all time again with very
little marketing compared to something
like Indiana Jones or mission impossible
so what explains all this
the answer is that people are are still
interested in films they are still
interested in the art form the pandemic
hasn't changed that
no matter what the AP and Hollywood
Executives tell you what has changed is
that people have grown tired of
Hollywood mainstream films are redundant
and Hollow and blatantly politicized
it's an industry entirely out of ideas
and people are noticing
and they're also noticing that it treats
its customers with contempt
that's what's really underpinning the
crisis
and it's why despite what the Panic
Executives and journalists will tell you
the collapse of the mainstream
entertainment industry would be no
tragedy in fact it's a necessary step in
the process of creating something
sustainable an industry that produces
content people actually want to watch
and that industry is coming
or the Hollywood Executives and
screenwriters want it or not
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed